こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんうまい棒って知ってますか
あの国民的お菓子甘い以降でございます今日はですねそういったトリックでを濃度を
いただきましたうまい棒は油でできているんでおやつと爆発するらしいですぜひやって
みてください
わかりました是非やりましょう用意するものはこちらスプレー若干
ボール甘いも以上でございますよさっそくやっていきましょう今日は前売りが短くて
言って
ありがとう4階今回3種類用意させていただきましたコーポターズ篤人
チーズアンストたこ焼き味でございますだーっ
危ないであんまりマネしないで下さいやってるように見えるんですけど全部ね cg
グラフィックの合成れ日は出てるね
死体が爆発するんでねやる時はじゃあ本当に爆発するのかさっそくやっていこうと思い
ますまずうまい棒チーズは力です
粉誰のいたずらだ
危ないとかいいんですねこういうなんか大変方さを使って作る調理方法とかまずんじゃ
まいちゃんの調理ですねこんな感じで誰もねあんまり信じてないんだよね
ざきます
電話やば嘘調理で沿い
ガツンの注意ん2うわぁファイヤ
皆せろ
あっはぁっ
re re
雨爪で美味しいなんか絶命に苔名とかもついてなんかめっちゃ香ばしい
これ普通ならない子よりおいしいぞ
これ名は脱衣今後だーです
まじうまえずーライブロイシュ最後例えば事例
めっちゃコーバーしてるんだよねこれやばいが s 5位美味しい
できたてうまい棒という味がします
これおいしいは偶然みんなもね相撲後はちょっと高を燃やしたら今加工は水というかと
か10円の子で安いお菓子の味じゃなくなりますこんなと旨味の効いた出汁っていうか
動いてちょっとできてアプリにして食うととても美味しいです
皆さん是非試してみましょうじゃあ
場数しねえじゃねーよ